now to Turkey in Syria where hope is
fading fast to find survivors days
after the catastrophic earthquake rocked
the region the death toll has crossed 24
000 but there are still remarkable rescues
happening just today a team pulled five members
from a single family who were trapped for 129
hours that's more than five days but conditions
are growing more dangerous for Rescuers with every
passing moment in the southernmost province of
turkey debris fell onto a rescue member of a
team as he tried to reach trapped survivors he
was later rescued from underneath the rubble
by his teammates who had escaped the Fallen
debris Chris livesay is in the disaster Zone
with Rescuers who are working around the clock
the sun has set on the fifth day since the
earthquake hope is beginning to slip through
the Ragged fingers they've been digging
with Rescuers Are Climbing inside all
they've sliced and proof of this apartment
building that's come crashing down and it's one of
several scenes all in the span of one city block
it's one of the most apocalyptic things we've seen
to mention that we're smelling and tasting
because the air is thick with dust and with
smoke although similar scenes like this are
being played out all across the devastated area
in turkey's Southeastern city of adiaman they
now live among the rubble every one of them
with relatives inside battling both the grief
and the cold look at us says epec I don't have
any shoes I don't have any water to wash my hands
we have nothing there are more dead people here
than alive this city is a cemetery successful
rescues do still happen 15 year old ifair
sandwiched between slabs of concrete for 99 hours
she tells her saviors she'd like some ice cream
double chocolate or white chocolate he says before
pulling her limp body to safety and baby Aya which
means miracle in Arabic born amidst the rubble in
Syria thousands from around the world have offered
to adopt her but she'll live with an uncle but on
this block in adiaman there have been no rescued
children today Instead The Weeping daughter and
sister of gulsaroon it was her birthday last
Saturday two days before she went missing beneath
the debris her sister epec just had to bury their
mother and father if they started rescues one
or two days sooner perhaps they'd be alive she
says and my sister would be safe do you have any
hope left that your sister might still be alive
for CBS Saturday morning Chris
live say a diamond turkey